my name is David Estes ahwal and my film
is called a second chance mr. Sher
documentary about a veteran from the
Iraq war who was diagnosed with PTSD and
finds himself lost in civilian life as
he decides to get a support dog he
starts to acknowledge his emotional
scars from war and looks at a rescued
companion for a second chance at life
seven classmates and I made his film at
the University of Southern California
School of Cinematic Arts
then I'm a just it's like a videotape
it's playing in my head every night my
brain cat say hey it's a dream even when
I wake up for like three milliseconds
I'm like holy [ __ ] oh yeah I'm in Santa
Monica in California in United States of
America thousands of miles away I have
to go through that process still
I brought flowers just to put up here
just to honor you I really wonder would
you like to find anybody for you no sir
I'm just um I don't know where where's
the appropriate place you know I was
taking the amount of the random people
pass away I I can't look at that
when did you get him and he's gonna get
bigger now he's a soldier dog in that
hole you can pat him he's booked do you
know why they died that's okay